ce monsieur n'a rien à faire sur le sol
de la république
il a lui-même choisi de ne pas être
français je voudrais le répéter ici il
est d'une nationalité étrangère il est
radicalisée puisque les services vous
l'avez dit de la dgsi ont considéré
depuis 18 mois désormais qu'il devait
être richesse puisque désormais c'est
public il n'a rien à faire ce territoire
la république là je considère que des
prédicateurs étrangers antisémite qui
tiennent des propos qui ni l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes qui
considère que les attentats sont des
complots qui considère que les génocides
n'ont pas existé où ils sont très
exagérées ces messieurs n'ont rien à
voir sur le sol de la république et j'en
tirais donc toutes les conséquences et
effectivement je leur fais une affaire
pour la république merci beaucoup